i could see that she'd taken a bolt to
the head and she was dying in front of
my eyes which as a father
you you don't want to see i remember i
could see that the ceiling had fallen in
and there was a lot of smoke and ash on
the floor
i saw the people run and the way they
were running on the way they were
screaming
it was this mass panic
the atmosphere was really good it was
very lively everyone was probably the
similar age to me or maybe a bit younger
a bit older but like very similar
all teens it was great
we'd made the decision that we were
going to leave the concert early
so we were going to leave during the
encore as
i came out i i obviously went first and
eve was behind me
we actually brushed shoulders with
salman the terrorist
we left straight after the encore
because we wanted to get out in time we
didn't want to keep my mum waiting
we just walked i want to say five six
steps into the foyer before i press call
the bomb went off
[Music]
no police urgency hello
is anybody injured yes
[Music]
i was just hit with a force of like heat
i remember i didn't know what it was but
my instinct was to just curl up into a
ball
and protect myself i remember i could
feel myself being like thrown up and
down like i was in the waves when the
bomb went off
had we not been running we'd have been
literally
right in the not right next to him and
we wouldn't be here
[Music]
i tried to stand up and look around to
see for my friend amelia
but i was quite i couldn't really see
very well like
my vision was very blurry i remember
looking down that was the first thing i
looked at was like
my legs and i saw like holes in a bit of
blood
and then that and then i like touched my
hands and i looked at my hands and i
thought oh my god what was this
i didn't want to worry her but i could
tell she was
really badly bleeding out she was losing
a lot of blood really fast
and she just kept saying to me like
millie i'm going to die millie this is
the time i'm going to die i
remember seeing an arm and the bottom of
a leg
and kind of looking down at me and
checking both my arms just to make sure
that it wasn't me
and thankfully i still had obviously
everything
and it was still attached and that's
kind of when i knew
you know something something serious had
happened i saw the people run and the
way they were running on the
way they were screaming it was this mass
panic
[Applause]
one of my daughters was in my bedroom
looking on my phone and
when i inquired what she was doing she
said well i
just want to check if martin texted you
or tried to ring you
because his mates keep messaging me they
can't find him
all i was bothered about as a dad was
making sure eve
was stayed alive basically obviously i
could see that she'd taken a bolt to the
head
and she was dying in front of my eyes
which as a father
you you don't want to see
probably about 45 minutes after the
attack happened
i just had the strangest of feelings i
just literally felt as if somebody got
some invisible scissors
and cut something off i just felt
suddenly he wasn't
here anymore i needed to call lucy's mum
on my one because
i thought what if there's other bombs or
other exits so i remember i kept saying
to lucy like
um what's your password for your phone i
can't unlock it because my fingerprint
id
wouldn't unlock it because i had a
fingerprint id on lucy's phone
and um i couldn't understand why it
wasn't working and when i looked down
that's when i saw that like three of my
fingers was really badly injured and
hanging off like i didn't
think it was real i remember i could see
inside the bones of my fingers
and i just like touched it and i
couldn't feel anything i'm just walking
through the
bodies and like a lot of rubble and
stuff and i came across
sharon who was laying there she was
literally in a
pool of blood so i took off my belt
and i wrapped it around just above the
wound and
i held it there in place so i saw for
you i'll stop that because she was
bleeding quite heavily and
i just wanted her to lock up at the
ceiling because uh if she looked
she looked to her right and there was
the bomber's leg
which was just down along it wasn't
connected to his body
i still remember the smell and almost
like a
smoky type of atmosphere
um very quiet obviously there are
screams there's people obviously dying
and things like that but
you know it's not like there was a lot
going on because either people ran out
if they could
or it was either you were you were dead
dying or
like me seriously injured in the wrong
wall
and i look at this young girl
[Music]
she was a very young girl uh i could
tell when she was
just to the left of me and say about
five meters to the left of me
but then i'm trying to focus on sharon
and i can see her
uh in the corner of my eye and i can see
that she's screaming
and she's just one she wants her mom she
was screaming for her mom
and she was being attended to by other
members of staff
they tried to stand her blood flow with
her injuries
but unfortunately she didn't make it
i think
[Music]
that was just like
one of the main regrets of our time
which i could just uh somehow save her
the paramedics wanted to take me first
but i said look i ain't going anywhere
you take my daughter
i'm not going to make it so stop wasting
your time with me
that's my last kind of sight that's when
i go right done my job
and yeah where the curtains come down
and then i i don't see anything then for
a good two weeks
i was told he died very very quickly he
died in a third of a second which is
very fast there was i was told there was
no room for
any active thought he was in a very very
good mood that evening he was very drunk
and
for once as a mother i can say i was
really happy that one of my children was
very drunk that night
i went straight to a e and they assessed
me and i
went down straight away to theater for a
14 hour surgery
shrapnel injuries are caused by pieces
of um
flying metal these injuries were nothing
like
i had ever seen before in all my years
working in an operating theatre
and i think the only way you could have
had experience of that would have been
working in a major trauma center or
working in the military the the expert
said it was like being shot at point
blank range 22 times
so a bolt hit me in the side of the neck
severed two arteries
should have gone straight through but it
didn't for some reason i ended up
swallowing it
so they found it in my stomach so that
was
one uh the second one hit me in the
center of the back
that totally severed my spinal cord i
didn't realize straight away that i'd be
paralyzed but
you know they kind of said you know you
know you're not probably gonna walk
again i'm gonna be in a wheelchair for
the rest of your life
and yeah gutted gutted
you know we're not going to be defeated
uh we're not going to be battled by
uh by these extremists um they want to
divide us
uh great monster is a place that
believes in standing together and we
will
[Music]
if you're going to try and divide people
the worst place to do it is manchester
and i think we saw that you know the the
outpouring of love
support the way that not just manchester
the whole of the uk came together and i
felt that in my bed
[Music]
hi martin hi eve it's david beckham here
i just wanted to know that we're really
thinking about you at this difficult
time i've heard
how much you've been fighting and how
tough you've been
i also hear that you're mad manchester
united fans i send my love we're
fighting with you and for you
and i hope to get to meet you soon lots
of love
i didn't really speak to lucy um
until she woke up from her coma i
remember um
that she messaged me she snapchatted me
and she was just like hi
and i was like oh my god like i screamed
and i ran to home and i started crying i
was like mom lucy's awake she
snapchatted me
and then she went back to sleep and
didn't snapchat me for two hours and i
thought she died again
but i still felt happy that she was
finally snapchatting when she was awake
people thought you know it's happened
now
it's two years onwards it's it should be
all right by now my parents and my
family members they said the same just
said
the thing is just didn't understand how
bad it was and
i just felt like i didn't belong there
anymore i just didn't belong
um on earth anymore i think part of me
died on that night part of me or if not
all of me died of that night
but the my physical self is still here
and i'm somehow trying to pick up all
the pieces and put them back together
the first two years after the bomb i was
very
numb and i was like a very angry person
who wasn't angry at the situation i was
angry at myself because i
suffered a lot with survivor skill so
i was just angry at myself for not
having worse injuries than lucy
not having worse injuries than the
people who had died why
i thought why haven't i died
when he had that rook suck on his back
and walked over that glass bridge into
the foyer
in his mind he must have thought i'm
doing the right thing for my cause and
i'm gonna die with it for it
um but you know the problem is the real
um
culprit of all of this is not the people
that are used to carry out these
heinous tasks it's it's the
organizations the ideology behind it
that
is really to blame they don't strap the
bombs around themselves they send other
people's children and
and sons and daughters to carry out
those tasks
so that is why um talking to young
people is so important to me
he claimed to be a muslim he claimed to
be doing this as god's work
well being being as a muslim it
i felt i felt like what i did on the
night was
a symbol of what true islam is i think
islam
and the teachings i was taught as a kid
as
a child those are the core principles
that
allowed me to actually make that first
thought of going in that helping these
people in the first place
i know how luck i am and eve is to to
still be here because we shouldn't be
here
so she went to the manchester children's
hospital
and she was there for nine months so it
was a long time
and again give it given her injuries you
know that didn't
hold out much hope for her you know very
much like a daddy
she's uh defied the uh the experts she's
back at school now full time she goes to
a different school
uh she goes to a special needs school
now so she's in a wheelchair
she's gonna need care probably for for
the rest of her life 24 hour care
plenty of times when i said to myself
you know what let's just go and jump off
a bridge and let's just
let's just end it i just can't take it
anymore
but that was just this voice saying to
me that
what's mine if you create now there's
you're not going to see what's what's
planned for you there's something so big
in life that's you can have to go get it
but and you just
keep going just keep going and it will
be all right
so i decided to forgive the guy who who
did the attack at the arena and um to me
forgiveness is really about um
freeing my soul and and enabling me to
to retain my own power without that
forgiveness
my head would have been filled with
anger and hatred
and that would have resulted in me not
functioning as a mother wife or
grandmother in september of this year
i'm going to be
climbing kilimanjaro with one of the
nurses
from salford royal that looked after me
and
one of the members of the public that
ran in and helped
i'm hoping to raise a million pounds for
the spinal injuries association for
which i'm a trustee
i don't think about the attackers
anymore they're irrelevant to me i'm
getting on with my life as much as i can
i mean i can't walk long distances i
can't but like i'm
i'm okay that i can do bits and i'm
happy with that considering what
happened this year i actually went to
uni with lucy
we've got we do the same course and we
live in the same flat
i think you've got to think about the
good things that's come out of this
situation
me and lucy have been bonded for life
now like we're always going to be
friends we always
know how each other feels and we're
always there for each other
[Music]
i can't bring him back i couldn't save
him from what happened
but i can now do this for him so that
his death hasn't been for nothing
that's the first chance we had to see
what was going on in the north tower
probably the worst 30 seconds of my life
furniture and paper and
people being pulled through those
holes in the building and out against
their will